there's something about um doing a set
like a late night set
and you know you're bombing
but you have to change it
in the spot in the moment and you have
to survive in those situations
and i think the roasting and poking
and a little bit of bullying is healthy
because i do
because when somebody is bombing on the
tonight show
right and they've done thousands of sets
in the or right and bombed in the or
they know how to handle it right there's
something about
bombing you know um magic
with honor right you we bomb with honor
all the time
where it's like it's not going well but
you know what i'm going to win this
right the audience is not going to
[ __ ] beat me yeah right
and you walk off stage you can sleep
that night right you go wow they
really did beat me i really didn't think
they were gunna yeah
have you ever had a ball a bomb that
sits with you i
was headlining in philadelphia where i'm
from
helium two christmases ago no um uh
what's the other one
the one they had one in uh san francisco
punch line punch line yeah punchline and
my mom came my parents came and my mom
it was christmas she threw a wrapped
present onto the stage when i was
three minutes in and had not won the
audience yet
so then i had to take the present and
address that something had been thrown
at me i had to then
your headlining i'm headlining i had to
then introduce my mom
i had to then unwrap the present
i had to explain it was a my mom is
was at the time i was owned an ebay
drop-off store
[Laughter]
for a hobby because she didn't make any
money but um she liked seeing the things
and um doing the research and so she had
gotten all these things from a nursing
school and one of the things she got was
a
a fake arm that had that nurses were
using to poke
ivs in and stuff so it had like fake
cuts in it it was this like arm
and when she sent me when she threw up
the box i went what is this one of those
rubber fists like yeah yeah and then it
ended up being kind of one of the rubber
and then it was like hard to and then
i'd be like
my mom has an ebay drop-off store like
the four deal virgin but it was after
that and it's
and i j it was just like this a lot of
explanation i was so hurt that my mom
was heckling me physically with
objects i was so upset yeah and then i
didn't want to hurt my mom so i didn't
want to like
yell at her or kick her out that i just
bombed like the entire it was just the
most uncomfortable sweaty
i felt so kind of like unsafe and all
that it just was really bad
those are the worst ones because
especially when you have like 30 or 40
minutes ago
right and you're bombing hard and
there's nothing that you can do
like you threw out your best joke right
and it got nothing they got nothing
and now you're in it right and
you can't really show what you
feel right you can't this is how you
feel
oh [ __ ] i want to go right you have to
still do a
yeah you guys didn't like that one
either huh but yeah inside you're
feeling this thing oh my god when you
have to end with going like well take
care
[Laughter]
i hope you guys uh do well in life i'll
never see you again right yeah
or um or then early on when i was
headlining i would steal like hacky
you know what i mean jokes like you know
me oh you're cancelled
what canceled yeah i would say stuff
like um
um i'm available for children's parties
after you say a dirty joke yeah
right the go-to or the go-to's right and
then
people are like bill hey mom when you're
at it bill hicks did that yeah
oh you're like oh [ __ ] you know what i
mean when they catch you that's bad
yeah i also i bombed an entire weekend
at foxwoods casino
entire weekend the most painful like
that was the worst i've i've never been
back
one time right i remember doing foxwoods
there was a curtain right i laid with my
shirt off
on this curtain like this and i was
crying
i was crying i could still see the
audience get up
that was the most weird show that was a
weird way they had sofas in the front
too
yeah yeah i just remember being the bag
like this crying
and just another thing you just can't
contemplate your life
yeah no i thought i should quit i was
like i should do good commercial acting
yeah okay so i at that time i had a show
on e
that literally no one watched but i got
a little bit like
okay i've made it it was after chelsea
ended and then e was doing like all of
these sample shows and stuff
yeah yeah and i was like you know i
didn't let myself go as far to be like
i'm the next chelsea or anything like
that but i was like
maybe i'll have a show and i can just
tour and i'll be fine
no so i've been focusing on the show and
then i was like guys i gotta leave early
i gotta leave on thursday because i'm
doing a weekend it's gonna be great i'm
a headliner
and um i fly out to connecticut
and of course it's kind of close to some
friends i have you know i'm like people
from college or
i'm like come on it's gonna be great
we'll go to the casino
i mean i bombed from the second i said
one girl was like you're not funny and i
was like you're being well you're
actually bad at your job too because
you're supposed to be laughing like
you're
and then they're all like
[Laughter]
and then of course my openers are the
hackiest pieces of [ __ ] and they're
crushing they're doing so i know and
then my openers who are so bad are
coming up to me like do you want some
tips and i was like
absolutely not get away from me but what
but what is it
and then at my last show it was
on sunday night the owner's son who also
does stand up
was like do you want an edible and i was
like no i'm not going to smoke and go on
stage am i going to get high on stage
and he goes
it can't get worse and i'm like give me
the out of b
and he was right because and then my
opener was bombing for the first time it
was so exciting
he hadn't bombed the entire weekend he
was bombing so hard
and he was sweating and he did 45
minutes because he was trying to get a
laugh
right never got it i was like join my
club [ __ ] wouldn't get off the
stage they're lighting him over and over
again by the time he gets off the stage
i'm the highest i've ever been in my
life
and i was like oops yeah and then it
ended up being fun because i was just
[ __ ] around and stuff but it was just
so bad so then on the plane ride home
i'm weeping okay i'm just crying
so hard i'm i have the window seat
and then there's this black guy next to
me he's about 50
okay he's in a suit he looks like a good
guy but you don't know yet until you
talk to him yeah so he goes
what's wrong he's an accident african
accent and i go oh i just you know i
i just had a bad weekend i am a comedian
i bombed the entire show it was so
painful my friend from college came i'm
so humiliated
and i go um what do you do and he was
like oh wait first he goes maybe you
should try thinking
he's like you know what i think you need
to do you need to try thinking about
other people
he goes try doing something for someone
else and it was
so cutting and so true but like painful
and then i go okay well what do you do
and he's like
i'm a doctor i was born in africa i was
the only person in my village to get out
i won a scholarship
i went to france i studied i got my
degree i now
work with doctors without borders i'm
going back to africa to save aids babies
[Laughter]
and i was like do you want free tickets
to the comedy yeah
yeah yeah it was just so humiliating it
was like an angel next to me
yeah he was like try volunteer work
was like try doing something selfish it
also feels good
the worst is when you have an opener a
local opener and they do a reference
and the audience laugh yeah just like
benningham junction
and the whole people laugh and you're
like funny can't jump
[ __ ] you i mean and then it's like
you because you don't know the area yeah
right and people laugh at [ __ ]
local [ __ ] that you don't not even
[ __ ] aware of just like the tits on
the highway five you're like what
is this you know what i mean because
there used to be
you know the uh on the um i think it's
the five
cat pelton yeah they have those nuclear
right and they look like breasts
so headliners